♪ ♪
ALEX: I'm headed down
to my new plot of land,
Sipsy comes running out of
the woods down there and
he's got this in his mouth.
It's a, I don't know
if he caught it,
it doesn't have
any marks on it.
I have no idea how it died,
I, maybe he
just grabbed it and
throttled it and
that's a successful hunt.
So Sipsy just literally
killed us dinner.
Come on Sipsy, come on.
Hey. No, no, no, no, uh-uh.
You'll get him, don't worry.
This definitely seems
like a good omen.
I'm not superstitious
but, you know, if I was,
I would definitely
think this was a sign
of good things to come.
That's my boy.
ALEX: Come on, Sipsy.
Time to go.
My new land is, is located
quite a bit closer to an area
where I know I
can hunt beavers.
There's moose, maybe ducks,
and generally
just good hunting.
If I can build like
a small kind of hunting
slash trapping cabin,
you know, just a real
basic shelter that could make
it easier for me to
hunt throughout the winter.
NARRATOR: Alex Javor's main
hunting grounds are two hours
from his A-frame
cabin by foot.
A dangerous journey in
the harsh Alaskan winters.
In order to protect
himself from being
stranded along the way,
Alex plans to build a
safe haven shelter halfway
from his cabin to
the hunting grounds.
ALEX: This is kind of
what I'm looking for. Yeah.
I guess you just might call
it artistic or something.
I like to kind of,
like, put it where, like,
kind of where the land
wants it anyway, you know,
so we have, like, this
kind of this natural clearing.
You come in here,
clear out some of these trees,
kind of clear the area
out a little bit and use
those same trees to build
uh, kinda, just like
a really simple, um,
shelter basically
or something,
just something I
can build a fire in maybe
put a small camp stove in,
and I'm gonna get back.
Tomorrow's gonna be a long
day a lot of hard work.
BRENT: Conditions in
Alaska, are they ever ideal?
Uh, it all depends on
your point of view and
what your expectations are.
You can't have
any expectations,
you just kinda gotta deal
with whatever is thrown at you.
Ideal conditions
are all relative.
BRENT: This is generally
where I have my firewood and,
uh, as you can see
there's not a lot happening,
it's a pretty
sad firewood stash.
It's 20 degrees out and
winter has come and there's no
firewood put away, so it
means we go cut firewood.
Firewood is key
mainly because that's how we
heat two of our buildings,
and then on top of that,
probably the most important
thing is we cook fish every
day for the dogs and we
use wood to boil the fish.
It's an essential thing
for just feeding the dogs.
We have a lot of
cutting ahead of us.
It's a beautiful day so we're
gonna take advantage of that.
It just got to be done.
You've got to make it a
top priority starting now.
Let's see if we can
find some firewood.
All right, well, this
is the trail that goes up.
So Ida's still visiting her
family in Sweden so I'm out
here by myself definitely
missing a piece of the puzzle,
Ida takes care of a lot of
stuff around here and makes my
life a lot easier,
so I'm definitely missing her.
But I have to work.
This is the killing
fields right here,
this is where all the trees
are laying down on the ground.
Yeah, I think this
is my path here.
(chainsaw revs)
The lifestyle here
is basically nonstop.
Even though I work way more
than the average person does
in civilization, it's
totally worth it to me.
Out here you just figure
out a way to do it and
I think that's what really
draws me to this lifestyle.
You don't call anybody.
You don't ask for help,
you just get it done.
There's no give up out here.
I think that's
the general trail.
Looks decent enough.
We'll do a little
trial run with the machine
without a load and we'll,
uh, give it a go here.
I'm gonna really have to
regulate how big a loads that
I can take, with a heavy
load it can flip the machine,
it can do all kinds of things.
It's the lack of
deep snow is our biggest
challenge right now.
We can't really change
that so we've just got
to kind of work around it.
Pretty smooth sailing,
we got a trail in.
It works.
Progress, one step at a time.
KALEB: It's almost better
than taking them to school,
learning real life
application lessons that they
can carry into adulthood.
KALEB: All right.
You guys ready to go?
GILBERT: Uh-huh.
KALEB: Gilbert, over here.
Ellie, come on.
My kids are the next
generation and it's really
important for me as a father
to teach them all the skills
that I know for
living out in the bush.
Today we are heading out
to a beaver pond that's next
to the McCarthy Road.
These beavers have been
cutting down trees,
dropping them across the road.
So, we need to go
harvest a couple of them
and take it
as an opportunity to teach
my kids some new skills.
You guys ready to
get some beaver bait?
GILBERT: Uh-huh.
KALEB: Do you know what
beavers like to eat guys?
GILBERT: Trees.
KALEB: Green trees.
You know what we
call Cotton Woods?
GILBERT: Huh?
ELOVIE: What?
KALEB: Beaver candy, because
they like it so much.
I think it's important to
teach my children everything
that I've learned up
to this point and,
and hopefully more
as I get older.
That way someday, if they
choose to live this lifestyle,
they will be well-equipped
to live in a place like this.
As a kid I learned by just
getting out and doing it.
I believe it's important
especially children living in
rural areas like we are,
that they learn life skills.
All right, guys, let's
go trap us some beavers.
MICHAEL: You jump
on a snow machine and those
things will fail you
time and time again.
It's soul less.
You jump on an old-fashioned
freight sled with a bunch of
malamutes that look
like a picture from 100
years ago in Alaska.
That's got soul.
MICHAEL: I call this
the "15-Gallon Shuffle".
Five gallons of food.
You go back around
five gallons of water.
one more time and pick
up five gallons of poop.
The past week of dog
training by dog sled,
I had about a foot of
snow packed to work with.
Now, all the snow was melted.
I can't run my
sleds no more but their
training has to continue.
But I've got a winter
caribou hunt coming up,
so now is the time to switch
over to a fat tire bike and
just hope and wait
for more snow.
Chores are all done now
it's time get on the trail
and check it
after this bad
windstorm and this warm weather.
So when I clear a trail
and I hike around,
I like to bring my
retired sled dog Nina.
She is 11 years old and
she is the grandmother to all
these puppies down the hill,
which are going to be
great sled dogs this year.
Nina. Nina. Nina.
She's going, uh, deaf.
During this warm weather
the winds came, rains came,
trees were breaking.
I'm going to go ahead and do
a sweep of my local trails and
then jump on a bike
and start training up.
Winters can get rough,
it's dark, it's cold,
and a lot of people
just get hold up.
For me, these dogs,
they get me out,
they get me moving around,
and their excitement
rubs off onto me.
This season belongs to them.
Here I've got a birch
tree that's about falling
down over the trail,
so I'm just going to go
ahead and cut this one down.
Just to be on the safe side.
Any sort of wind when
this wood gets brittle,
it could snap and fall
in the coldest weather with
just a little bit of wind.
So, I'm going to try to
cut this with a hand saw.
Come here, Nina.
I need you to sit, right here.
Come here. Sit.
She's so deaf I have to
give her hand signals.
Since this is leaning,
it does have the
possibility to kick back.
It never feels like a safe
thing to do when I have to
clear stuff leaning like
this but might as well get
to work because this
is going to be awhile.
(sawing)
(wood cracking)
Come here, Nina.
Come on. Nina. Hey.
Nina. Go! Go!
MICHAEL: Come here, Nina.
Come on. Nina. Hey.
Nina. Go! Go!
Nee-nee, you're grounded.
No video games.
That thing fell quick.
It was leaning so strong.
I only got about
halfway in before it,
it snapped and it's a likely
deal that this would have fell
over the trail sometime.
And I don't want it to fall
on the trail when I'm on it.
It's good doing this physical
labor with hand tools.
I don't even use
an internal combustion
for really anything.
When you get out here it's
a little harsh at first.
Splitting wood by hand,
hauling water by hand,
running a dog team instead
of running a snow mobile.
It's a game for me to not
spend money on your things
that you want me to buy.
That's the game for me.
All right, we've
got this big birch tree
cleared off the trail.
Time to keep going,
I got four more
miles of trail to do.
I'll sleep good tonight.
PRODUCER: What it's like
being a father bringing your
two kids out and teaching
them some new lessons?
KALEB: Stressful.
KALEB: All right,
guys, let's go.
Bringing out the kids
on the ice is stressful.
Safety is number one on
an expedition like this.
I don't want my kids
to fall in the water.
I don't want them to get
wet which could put them
at the risk of hypothermia.
Are you guys getting wet?
GILBERT: No.
KALEB: Good.
You know its zero
degrees outside,
it's very easy
to get cold and not be
able to recover from that.
GILBERT: You will get cold.
Is it cold?
KALEB: Ah.
When I was about the
same age as Gilbert,
on one of the sets we were
doing when I was a little kid,
I actually fell in the hole.
My father reached down
and grabbed me before
I went under the ice.
And so, I've always been
really careful since then not
to be too close to the
edge of the water there.
Stay away from the hole, guys,
you don't want
to fall into that.
Once we cut a hole in the ice,
we stick the cottonwood
pole down in the center.
You put that down and they
just, they go nuts over it.
We'll shove it down in the mud
about as far as it will go.
Then we have two dead cross
poles that we stick over it.
We lash the cottonwood
pole to the dead poles and
then we hang snares
off the dead poles.
And that ought
to stay in place.
All right, guys,
lets grab the snares and
start hanging them in there.
GILBERT: Okay.
the pole got (inaudible).
ELOVIE: (inaudible) Oh!
KALEB: Oh, hey,
we snared the dog.
We've got you, Piper.
(Elovie shrieks)
Okay, that was really
loud and screechy,
but that was pretty funny.
GILBERT: Uh-huh.
KALEB: I'm hoping that all
of these little skills that I
teach them will set them up
for a great future if someday
they choose to
live out in the bush.
ELOVIE: Shovel me, dad.
Shovel me, dad.
KALEB: It's entirely their
choice but it really is a
pretty good life
out in the woods.
BRENT: It's basically
constant work.
It's a lot of problem solving,
a lot of improvising
and making things up,
it's the way of life
that I love and thrive at.
BRENT: Okay. So, yeah,
this is the stuff
Unfortunately, it's
all buried in the snow
but lots of good firewood.
A super heavy load going down
that trail would not be a very
good idea mainly just because
we don't have enough snow.
I'm gonna want to
take as much as I possibly
can down with every load.
I know that I don't want to
be there all day long so we're
going to find a happy medium.
If you hurt
yourself out here,
you're a long ways from help.
If you cut your finger off,
you're probably not going
to have that finger anymore.
It's, it's just
the way it is out here.
Well, so much for
a conservative load
but it's worth a shot.
Worst thing is it overtakes a
snow machine and flips over.
You've got to live
on the edge but not
that close to the edge.
I think we'll be okay.
Famous last words.
♪ ♪
Whoa! Oh (bleep).
BRENT: Oh (bleep).
We made it!
Feels awesome
to have the first load
of wood off the mountain.
It's totally doable
and once we get more snow,
it'll be,
I don't think, a problem at all.
It swings around quite a bit
but we made it down no problem.
I don't think
I'd want to haul much
heavier of a load than,
than that one.
Living out here, living
this kind of lifestyle,
efficiency is super important.
You just got to try and make
the best out of every trip,
wherever you're
going around here.
We're gonna be able to have
a nice warm cabin tonight.
So it's a start.
This will last us a few days.
We'll get a few more
loads so this pile will grow.
And then it'll shrink.
And then it'll
grow again, hopefully.
More firewood to get.
ALEX: Yeah. Some people,
especially when you're, um,
kind of miserable and
exhausted and cold and wet,
they might want
to know like,
"Don't you, like,
miss hot showers and
warm rooms and
stuff like that now?"
And, honestly I don't at all.
I don't think about it.
Um, that just comfort and
convenience just doesn't mean
anything to me.
NARRATOR: After finding
a suitable location,
Alex must now harvest
enough viable trees to
build his hunting shelter.
But with daylight and
temperatures quickly fading,
it's imperative that
Alex use every hour wisely
in order to get his cabin
built before it's too late.
ALEX: This is going to
be a good amount of work.
I think the fastest I
can do this would be, uh,
probably three days,
realistically.
I'm gonna make this
guy fall this way,
just 'cause it's clear path.
No obstructions.
But I'm gonna try to get it
done in two days but they're
gonna be really busy days.
So I should have
everything I need in here.
My goal is to get about 36
good logs for the walls and
then I can use pretty
much any dinky little
ones for the roof.
A log like this might be
fine for the, for the wall.
Definitely be
good for the roof.
One of the big challenges I'm
facing when I do this work is,
it's pretty warm,
which you'd think
would be nice but, uh,
it means all the snow,
it falls on me
and then it melts
and then I get really wet.
So then if I need to
stop and take a break,
because I'm getting tired,
uh, I get really
cold pretty quickly.
You know within an hour
you could have hypothermia.
So the only thing to do
is keep working, keep going.
It's not good to push too
far into being exhausted when
you're doing dangerous
work like this.
Uh, pushing to the point
where my hands are going
to slip and I'm gonna
slice myself with my own ax.
Still got a long,
long ways to go.
I don't know if I'll be
able to cut 36 down today,
we'll see.
But we'll just keep working.
It's really easy to become
lazy especially in modern life.
Everything's designed
for our convenience.
Every time we
increase technology to
benefit our convenience,
we kind of get a
little more disconnected
from the earth.
Just by going back
50 years and cutting my wood
with a saw and an ax.
Woo, it's heavy.
It just gives me
a lot more appreciation
for modern lifestyle.
Just so it's a little
bit uncomfortable,
you know it's, it's work.
But I feel like it keeps
you from getting lazy or
taking things for granted.
Woo.
That's enough
work for one day, I think.
I'll probably need some
more of the, maybe not.
I might have enough.
We'll see.
Well, I better get
home before I get cold.
So. I'm feeling
pretty exhausted.
Today I've made a huge mess.
I'll have to clean it up.
Tomorrow the real
struggle begins.
MICHAEL: Hunting with a
team of Alaskan Malamutes,
it's just priceless.
I couldn't picture
my life now without
hunting caribou by dog team.
MICHAEL: All right,
bike feels good.
Time to flip out.
Today's a good day.
Got the trail clear.
Got the studded
tires on this thing.
And I'll just keep running
dogs until they're all run.
All right, I'm gonna
start with the two rudest,
biggest, strongest
jerks in the lot.
The wheel dogs.
The ones that don't
listen well, Snoop and Kyran.
I gotta get out of
here in one piece.
My last run with
Snoop and Kyran,
they were so excited and they
were so amped up they slammed
me down onto the ground,
they ripped the
chain off the bike.
Being three or four times
the size of a race dog,
if they slam their harnesses
when I least expect it,
I'm going flying off a sled.
It's rough running dogs
but it humbles you too.
You gotta get a good
hold on that boy.
(grunting)
Ah (bleep).
He's too strong
for his own good.
It's been about three
days since they've ran.
So they're gonna
be really amped up.
The anxiety is gonna be high.
The dogs are gonna be
screamin', howlin', barkin'.
It's a mess but
if I can get out of the
yard upright on this bike,
I'll be good to go.
Stay. Stay. Stay.
Stay!
Whoa. Whoa.
Holy (bleep)!
MICHAEL: Get up there.
Whoa. Whoa.
Holy (bleep).
Good boys. Good boys.
All right,
we got out the door.
My knee is sore,
but I'll be all right.
These sled dogs,
these Alaskan malamutes,
there's something about
traveling with these dogs that
seems more real to
me than the automobile
on the asphalt road.
All right, the dogs'
gates look good.
We're going at about a
seven mile an hour pace.
They're both in unison.
They're not runnin' too
hard, they're not lungin'.
They're just hoofin' it.
This time of the year, to
not have snow is so weird.
But the training continues
by fat tire bike.
Human power.
Dog power.
Manzo malamutes.
A little bike ride
in the birch forest.
BRENT: People pay, you know,
tons and tons of money at
the gym or, or, you know,
the trainers or whatever
to keep them in shape,
but out here just normal
life keeps you in shape and,
and cuttin' wood is
just part of normal life.
BRENT: Yeah. Beautiful day,
nice and chilly.
Time to buck up some wood.
Wealth here is a big stack
of firewood, lots of dog food,
and warm temperatures.
But we have to deal with
whatever comes at us.
And wealth is definitely,
it's another relative term.
You have to be able to take
the punches and get back up
and keep going forward.
Technology allows us to
do all the things
that we have to do in
a more efficient way.
But it's definitely a good
workout splitting wood.
If I make it
to my mid-70s here,
I'll be a happy man.
If I can't split
this piece of wood,
I'm never gonna make
it here to my mid-70s.
Just the whole purpose
of cutting firewood,
it's gonna warm ya four or
five times before you actually
get it to the wood stove.
It's definitely
therapeutic at times.
I'm kind of checked out
away from normal society and
normal everyday
nine-to-five life.
Not knowing what
the next challenge you're
going to have to overcome,
and what the next
thing is going to be.
The uncertainty
of this life I think is
what I enjoy most about it.
That's it.
Last cuts for this pile.
Ah.
Yeah, well, got
a little supply.
It looks good to have a
wood pile around here.
Oh, yeah.
I see a warm
cabin right there.
KALEB: I've always enjoyed
being outside from the time
I was a little kid.
And so, it's great seeing
my kids learning to enjoy the
outdoors and the
cold and the snow and
just everything about being
out in the fresh clean air.
KALEB: Who's excited that we
get to check beaver sets on
Ellie's fourth birthday?
GILBERT: Me.
KALEB: That's pretty cool,
isn't it?
It's kind a special day
because it's Elovie's birthday.
It's pretty unique to be
able to take my daughter out and
go check beaver sets.
She seems pretty
jazzed about it.
And I don't know very many
four-year-old girls who go
beaver trapping with their
fathers on their birthday.
Guys, I see a
pole's tipped over.
You know what that means?
GILBERT: Trapped a beaver.
KALEB: Means a beaver's
been chewing on it.
All right, let's go check it.
All right, I'm checking the
ice here with my ice spud to
make sure it's
safe to walk here.
There is no guarantees
that we'll be successful.
Huh. Well, let's take a
peek and see what's in there.
There's a 50/50 shot that we
can come back with food or not
come back with food.
There's definitely a sense
of anticipation and just not
knowing what's gonna happen.
I love trapping season.
Oh, jeez.
GILBERT: Daddy,
what are those?
KALEB: I have no
idea what those are.
KALEB: Oh, jeez.
GILBERT: Daddy,
what are those?
KALEB: I have no
idea what those are.
Never seen bugs like
that in a pond ever.
Like, that is crazy.
ELOVIE: And they're not dead.
GILBERT: Uh-huh.
KALEB: I don't see any beaver.
It appears like we
might have got skunked.
Not a single beaver,
just a bunch of bugs.
Well, let's pull it up
and just take a look.
Look at that.
Right down at the bottom.
So our snares were right
at the top of the ice and
they hung down about
a little over a foot.
So somewhere in this range.
That's where
our snares were and the
beaver was clean down here.
So he came to the set and he
took our bait but he took it
where we didn't have
any snares to catch him.
He done outsmarted us.
It's a great lesson for the
kids to learn that you can't
necessarily be successful
every single time you
go into the woods.
It's pretty disappointing
but just getting out with them,
whether we're
successful or not,
is what makes this
trip a success.
GILBERT: Daddy,
see the bugs I got out?
KALEB: Yup. You just
reduced the bug population
by several million
next summer, probably.
Ready to go for a
little sled ride?
Come on, Ellie.
ELOVIE: It's on me.
KALEB: Don't walk in the hole.
We might not have gotten
a beaver today but it's
Ellie's birthday and so, uh,
we need to have some fun
with her and Gilbert.
Ready?
(laughing)
Our playground out
here is limitless.
We live in the middle of
a 13-million-acre park.
We may not have swing
sets in our park,
but we do have some pretty
awesome hills to go sledding
on and plenty of snow
to make that happen.
MICHAEL: It's been
a learning process for
those dogs and myself,
but it's in their blood.
They, they know what
to do from hundreds,
if not thousands
of generations.
MICHAEL: You want to go again?
You want to go again?
(barking and howling)
You can't knock a dog
for high motivation.
Time to finish up the
final run of the day.
Lead dog Mau.
Little female Cleo.
And one of their puppies, Red.
See the guy chewing
on his chain?
We're gonna run that
goofball over there.
Let's do this.
Next up is hookin' up
two veterans and one pup.
And the pup's lucky because
it's his mom and dad.
So they'll be on
the same brainwave.
Hopefully, theoretically.
This is impossible to put
a harness on this guy.
Training puppies is
probably one of the most
frustrating things ever.
People think
puppies are cute and
I just look at 'em like,
"Oh, my God, I've got
a lot of work ahead of me."
This is actually,
it makes for a good sled dog.
The most spastic one of
the bunch is also the
hardest working pup.
And maybe someday this
guy might be a lead dog.
You never know.
I need you guys to teach
this boy well, alright?
Might be hectic with three
dogs on a bike but I need two
veterans to teach a dog
what's right from wrong.
But still, puppies do all
kinds of crazy stuff so this
might be a hectic run.
Go get 'em. Yah, yah, yah!
Nice to get a little
bit of snow coming back.
It's promising.
Maybe after a couple
or more good storms
I'll be back on the sled.
We've got about two miles in.
We got to keep him moving.
The more he runs the
calmer he'll get.
This puppy has good focus.
It's very rare for a dog to
be this young and to be this
focused on being a sled dog.
And every time
I run this puppy,
he's gonna get a little bit
more focused and he's gonna
put all his energy
to good use.
Good dogs.
I find working with these
animals just as therapeutic as
it is for the animals
running the miles.
As an Iraq war
veteran with PTSD,
it really helps me cope
with a lot of my trauma and
it really excites me watching
puppies grow up and be strong,
confident courageous sled dogs.
And I love it.
ALEX: I think to live
out here you have to be
pretty stubborn and
bullheaded sometimes.
Uh, just, uh, just to
get through, you know,
tough challenges.
At the same time if
you go too far,
if you're not able to back out
into a wider perspective,
you can get yourself
in trouble that way.
ALEX: Think I'll need an ax.
This morning, uh,
I'm feeling good.
I'm trying to get this cabin
done before we get into the
depths of winter.
But now it's crunch time.
I have to finish it
and get it done quick.
Can get my hammer.
Uh, maybe I don't need that.
Today's task is gonna be
to start notching the logs,
stacking them up,
building the walls.
With the chainsaw and ATV,
I could just blast
through the work and
get it done quick and, uh,
if the result is your
only goal, that's cool.
Uh, for me it's the journey,
not the destination.
I'm gonna say the
stove is the kind of the
back end of the cabin.
So the back wall would be here
and then walls on either side.
Just keep it real simple.
I'm using just
a really classic log
cabin building technique.
You can just think of
it like a rectangle.
A rectangle that's designed
for me to crawl inside,
sleep in, and stay warm.
So it needs to room for
me and a wood-stove and a
little extra room
just to store some gear
or something like that.
This is a good technique
because it doesn't require
really any specialized tools.
It's just built very
simply by stacking up logs,
uh, and then you
put kind of a U-shaped
notch in them so they
fit over each other and nest
on top of another log neatly.
Let me just see
what that's like.
Huh. Good
enough for government work.
I'm just gonna be
eye-balling it,
going real fast even
if it's not air-tight.
That's fine.
It's just a survival
shelter really.
Hopefully, I can finish up.
My joints hurt.
I have no strength in my arms.
Uh, gripping the
ax feels unsafe.
You know, it feels
like I could drop it.
I'm just exhausted.
Uh, we're just putting
on the final logs.
That'll work.
And then I'll start laying
the roof in-between.
I'll, before I do
the roof though I
gotta frame in the door,
cut that out.
Yeah, I'm pretty,
pretty exhausted.
Uh, yeah, we're getting there.
Just about there.
(bleep).
Left my hammer at the cabin.
I'll try to make use of my ax.
(hammering)
(groans)
Ah, (bleep) piece of (bleep).
(hammering)
ALEX: (bleep)
piece of (bleep).
Um, I gotta get a hammer.
I can't do it like this.
I can't drive (bleep)
500 nails like that.
That'll take a (bleep) year.
Um, left my hammer
at the cabin.
Trying to hammer nails
with an ax is, uh,
exercise in frustration.
So I think I'm
gonna head up there real
quick and get my hammer.
It'll be worth it.
In the modern world,
you'd say time
is money but out here,
time's all you got.
So you don't want to waste it.
All this comes at a cost.
And it costs me a couple
of hours of daylight.
There's never, never
enough this time of year,
but I'll try to make use
of every hour I've got left.
(hammering)
There's only a couple
hours of daylight.
I don't prefer to work in the
dark so I'm gonna get straight
to it and work fast and
furious and try to get as much
work done as I can, uh,
before it gets dark.
I call this my framing.
Um, just hammer it in
to hold these guys.
Then I'll saw it right
in-between and then we can
lay the roof, I think.
If you don't got patience,
you're gonna get it,
'cause this is
gonna take a while.
(saw grinding)
What do you think, Sipsy?
Do you want to go in there?
It looks like a
safe cozy spot,
where you're protected
on three sides.
Kind of like a den?
He's making a, there you go.
If Sipsy approves, I'm happy.
That's the only
one that matters.
The roof's really simple.
I just take all the thinner
trees that weren't big enough
for walls and layer
them across the top.
On top of all that,
I'm just gonna layer
all these extra
spruce prawns that we
had around that will
act as insulation.
It's not particularly
fire safe,
and it wouldn't
keep the rain out,
but for a winter hunting
cabin, it'll get the job done.
I finished the cabin.
Mostly I feel relief
that the work's done,
but I also am excited to,
uh, test it out, you know,
kind of like a new toy.
And, uh, see if it
burns down immediately.
♪ ♪
♪ They come with
bows and arrows ♪
♪ They come with ♪♪
ALEX: It's working,
it's working.
This is right.
Yeah, I'm actually really
looking forward to go hunting
because I can
definitely use the meat.
Coming back and spending
the night out here,
it's gonna be,
it's gonna be cool.
♪ We are the hunted,
we are the chosen ones ♪♪
BRENT: Being out here,
being out with the dogs or
just being out cuttin'
firewood just feels free.
You guys hungry?
You guys want
something to eat?
It just takes a lot of work
but it's all worth it because
of that feeling of freedom.
Forward progress, every day.
That's all you gotta do,
is make a
little forward progress.
(barking)
MICHAEL: You want a
little bit of fat?
You gotta sit.
Sit. Good boy.
You did good today.
These sled dogs, they want
to go and they want to explore.
They re-invigorate my spirit.
That's why I'm a
dog musher for life.
Until I'm an old man and
my body can't move anymore,
I'll be a dog musher
until the end.
KALEB: Life for the Rowlands,
out here in the
middle of the wilderness,
is just beginning.
One day at a time,
one lesson at a time.
BRITTNEY: Ta-da!
GILBERT: Wow.
BRITTNEY: Look what I made.
I think what Kaleb
and I have out here is
pretty special and unique.
♪ Happy birthday to you. ♪♪
BRITTNEY: And I really love
that we were able to do that
together and we've
created such a lovely
place to call our home.
♪ If we are the hunted
then we are the chosen ones. ♪♪
BRENT: Every day is a
knock down drag out fight.
But it's what
we signed up for.
MICHAEL: Right now,
the snow is coming back
and the deep dark winter
is coming upon us.
♪ We are the hunted ♪♪
BRITTNEY: We're the next
generation of Alaskans.
Our children are the future.
♪ We are the chosen ones ♪♪
ALEX: Alaska's definitely a
place for people who want to
live in a continual challenge.
Mother Nature doesn't quit,
she doesn't tire.
And the challenge never ends.